a new flat for Maria and her family
it's been more than a year since they
were displaced
she says the fierce fighting in Mario
Paul destroyed their home
a flat was damaged in the fighting but
we have already been given new housing
we submitted the paperwork and waited
for six months two days ago we got a
call from the housing department saying
that the papers are ready and they give
us the keys we are moving in with our
remaining Furniture we will buy what we
don't have and move on
she joins hundreds of families in this
city who've received the new Flats
workers are scattered across the city's
damaged buildings their mandate is to
change the face of Russian control
module what this isn't an easy task the
Russian government estimates the total
cost of rebuilding to exceed two billion
dollars over three years with the amount
of Destruction and the slow pace of
reconstruction it will probably take
much longer
more than 1600 Flats have been issued we
expect the same number of Apartments
this year the work's being done there
are just not enough workers for us to
accept the number of applications to
process quickly and in a timely manner
some who preferred not to talk on camera
complained about serious delays and the
need to pay bribes to get their
paperwork done
there's a problem but these are isolated
cases because unfortunately we're
working with documents many people had
their documents destroyed during combat
operations it took a psychological toll
and many Financial expenses to restore
the documents only then can you nudge
the documents on the queue for a flat
most of the new projects are built
around the city and the Heart of Mario
Paul several old buildings have been
damaged
including this famous drama theater
that's being rebuilt
in March last year the theater was hit
during the Russian push to take the city
there were hundreds of deaths and
injuries Ukraine says it was caused by a
Russian aerial attack Amnesty
International has also accused Russia of
targeting the theater knowing civilians
were Sheltering inside Russia denies
these allegations
Russia wants to rebuild mayuple as a
city of its own design but that would
mean replacing or revamping some iconic
landmarks the Azog star steel plant was
the last Ukrainian holdout in the city
the Russian plan is to transform it into
a vast business park with green spaces